nasa says it will release new images
today of the most
distant object ever explored by humans
this photo of fuzzy photo of ultima
thule was taken by the pioneering new
horizons spacecraft yesterday
scientists believe the icy world more
than a billion miles beyond pluto
will reveal clues about the origins of
the solar system
mark strassman is at the missions
headquarters in laurel maryland near
baltimore mark good morning
good morning scientists here are now
studying the first of hundreds of
images the new horizons space probe will
send back to earth
over the next 20 months or so these
pictures will be
more detailed and potentially more
stunning
than images the same probe took of pluto
three and a half years ago
we are ready for ultimo slowly science
transmission
new horizons radio signals arrived on
earth tuesday morning
to cheers after traveling more than 4
billion miles through the cosmos
this is what it recorded an icy world
nicknamed
ultimate thule latin for beyond the
borders of the known world
on the frozen fringes of the solar
system it's one of
thousands of known objects in the kuiper
belt new horizons flyby whiz past it
at more than 32 thousand miles per hour
alan stern is the mission's principal
investigator
it's just unprecedented no one's done
anything like this in space flight ever
before his team has planned for this
moment since 2015
when new horizons sailed past pluto and
took these dramatic images
how complicated was getting the two to
in the same neighborhood
every part of this is hard ultimate
thule
is basically the size of a mountain we
chased it down from a billion miles away
more or less in the dark
and we completely nailed this ultimate
thule is shaped like a bowling pin
and about 20 miles across higher
resolution photos to be released later
today
will show whether it's a single world or
two in very close orbit
it's been frozen in time for four and a
half billion years
since the birth of the solar system and
scientists hope
it can help explain how planets like
earth were formed
never have we ever been to a perfectly
preserved relic
of the formation days of the planets and
in the next few days we're going to
start to unravel what that was all about
and that's priceless scientifically
new horizons will now just keep moving
deeper into the cosmos
as scientists here try to decide what it
should target next
michelle amazing stuff wow it sure is
it's
really cool stuff really cool stuff
a galaxy far far away yes it is but you
know it's just a rock right
now
all right thank you mark